tomorrow rishi sunak will tell the
people of leicester and up and down the
country that there are limits to what he
can afford he will impose a new ceiling
new fiscal rules on the financial help
he can offer but it's these people and
their businesses post covid post brexit
all grappling with the cost of living
crisis
so they'll all contain
finnish stark and ingredients in there
how far will the chancellor's promises
meet their needs
what's the biggest challenge today the
biggest challenge without question is
actually workforce and trying to recruit
staff before kovid we were having
10 15 people a week knocking on the door
looking for work
now that's actually down to zero and
then not only that there's so much
competition out there within uh within
leicester where people are offering
different rates of salary that the staff
have become quite mobile
and so you're having to do things to
keep them interested and motivated
motivating staff tomorrow will mean
giving british workers a pay rise they
will announce a higher minimum wage of 9
pounds 50 and higher salaries for 5
million public sector workers but will
it be enough as prices are also rising
quickly just through here is where
actually a lot of the production
actually happens nilam runs dolly's
cookies producing and distributing three
to four hundred cookies a day
she says government needs to dial up
rather than down post covid financial
support for business
i think just like any other business
we've actually um obviously been hit
quite hard with covid
i think loan rates are still high and i
feel like
just kind of having grant funding or
just support available some postcovid
support will be available the
government's set to announce a six-month
extension to the recovery loan scheme
until june next year but any loans not
grants on offer
this is where the pre-cooked food goes
in to be pasteurized or sterilized for
james turner whose equipment increases
the shelf life of processed food the
retention of a skilled well-trained
workforce is what he wants the
chancellor to address
i think we're really looking to improve
the skills and the skill set of
certainly younger people coming up
through the
through the education system
to improve knowledge and
uh and awareness of thermal processing
could tomorrow deliver
rishi sunac will unveil a three billion
pound investment for post 16 education
to ensure people have the necessary
adult training but is it enough in a
chronically underfunded sector
the pictures the chancellor wants you to
see supplied today by the treasury are
of someone keeping a tight reign on
budgets rather than delivering a sugar
rush to the economy but billions have
been splashed in advance of the budget
in a series of pre-announcements much to
the irritation of the common speaker
it is not right for everybody to be
briefed it's not more important to go on
the news in the morning it's more
important to come here let's get this
message across these are the elected
members that represents this united
kingdom it is not done through sky tv
the speaker isn't the only one annoyed
by some of the spending demands
leveling up boris johnson's promise
turning into rishi sunax nightmare
whether it's funding for skills money
for farmers or dealing with high energy
bills every single cabinet minister now
says their pet demand is part of
levelling up but rishi sunnah can't
afford it all
this isn't an austerity budget but nor
is there money for tax cuts
the same things that have driven up
tax and spend this year in particular
the need to spend on health and social
care driven in part by an aging
population those things aren't going to
go
away and my guess is that over the next
decade whatever might happen over the
next two or three years the overall
level of taxation will probably continue
to rise the chancellor will have more
money to play with than many expected
but he wants to be remembered as prudent
that will mean some lose out sam coates
sky news